is it fair a question on the lips of the
nation
today our social justice put to test but
who feels they benefit and who feels
they're losing out is it fair or unfair
that national insurance is increasing to
fund social care very unfair why why do
you think it's very unfair i don't know
i think i know we've got to get social
funding um
back up and running again but i don't
think that's the right way to do it
that's all
why do you think it's fair well i think
we need to invest in
care of that nature given what's been
happening i find it okay because i i can
afford to
to give that away but i guess i guess
people in a last situation wouldn't say
the same thing uh i'm not sure actually
no i don't follow that i'm actually i'm
actually might go unfair to be honest
not very unfair i'd probably go i think
why'd you both think unfair
uh because i think for me it's sort of
like i wouldn't target the people who
are making up between 24k like 50k i
feel like there's obviously people
making much more than that who are
clearly the issue
when the romans ruled the streets of
chester there was no such thing as
national insurance but today the people
of this city were well aware of the
incoming changes i work in health and
social care and i think it's good that
money will be coming to hell well i
don't think the whole country should
suffer when there's other ways and means
you know there's multi-millionaires
sitting there and they're going to
increase tax on people who are on
minimum wage or you know even going
higher and higher so there's got to be a
better solution out there the prime
minister said the costs would be split
as fairly as possible
for some that promise just doesn't help
pay the bills
we're surviving really but there's not
enough and then more of this is going to
be taken away from us we're not we're
not going to cope
so what does the levy actually mean for
people's wallets to be fair i think it
makes a huge difference because um
well i'm still young i still spend a lot
of money on going out and all that stuff
and for a young person to get what so
run about 130 some like 130 quid
that's significant yeah and how do those
who will benefit from social care feel
we think it's unfair
no i don't think so i don't think these
people should pay no i don't either they
too don't get off scot-free but people
like nina and elizabeth feel a
suspension of the triple lock on
pensions is worth it i think it's fair i
think that's gradual that's gradual
that'll suit me i don't care there's no
doubt this city's mixed views will be
reflected across the country but whether
you think it's fair or unfair a change
in the care system is needed and now
it's happening in saman rashid sky news
chester